- [Tutor] In this video, we're
going to talk a little bit
about how modern technology
like social media
has enhanced the communication
power of the presidency.
Now, being president
has a lot of advantages,
but politically one of
those advantages is that
as president, you're
automatically newsworthy.
So cameras and shows
are gonna be interested
in talking to you, hearing
what you have to say.
Now, this has always been
the case for presidents.
If they wanted to publish
an editorial in a newspaper
back in the 1790s, they
could have done that.
But one major advantage
that presidents have today
is advances in communication technology.
And by that, I mean not only
the wealth of media choices
that are out there in terms of channels
and methods of distribution like YouTube,
but also social media
like Facebook or Twitter.
So why would presidents be interested
in using social media in the first place?
Well, check out this graph
from the Pew Research Center
that shows how much the
following of politicians
has grown in just four
years, from 2010 to 2014.
You can see that it doesn't
matter how old someone is
or whether they're Republican or Democrat.
Across the board, the
percent of registered voters
who follow candidates for office
has doubled in just this short time.
So what does this mean for
the president in particular?
Well, one thing it does
is make it much easier
for the president to do
something called going public.
And going public is when
the president goes
directly to the electorate,
speaks directly to the people
to gain support for their policies.
So they're bypassing members of Congress
and speaking directly to the electorate
to try to drum up support
for whatever policy they'd like to enact.
And the range of diverse media outlets
that serve different demographics
means that it's pretty
easy for the president
to speak directly to whichever demographic
he or she's interested in talking to.
So they can craft a message
that appeals to one specific demographic.
For example, let's take a look at
an appearance that former
president Barack Obama
made on the internet
show Between Two Ferns.
- Have you heard of the
Affordable Care Act?
- Oh yeah, I heard about that.
That's the thing that doesn't work.
Why would you get the
guy that created the Zune
to make your website?
- Healthcare.gov works great now,
and millions of Americans
have already gotten
health insurance plans.
And what we want is for people to know
that you can get affordable healthcare.
And most young Americans,
right now they're not covered.
And the truth is is that
they can get coverage,
all for what it costs to
pay your cell phone bill.
- [Tutor] So you'll
notice that in that clip,
Obama was speaking
directly to young people,
going through a show that young
people were likely to watch
and even using language that
was geared toward young people,
like saying that healthcare costs
about as much as your cell phone bill,
all in service of trying
to promote the policy
of the Affordable Care Act.
Barack Obama was also the first president
to create an official presidential
Twitter handle @POTUS,
President of the United States,
which then in the transfer of power
from the Obama administration
to the Trump administration
now is the official Twitter
handle of Donald Trump.
And Trump is particularly
well known for using Twitter
to reach a broad audience.
Check out this tweet
from July 5th, 2018, which talks about
Trump's position on immigration laws.
So let's read these.
Congress must pass smart, fast
and reasonable immigration laws now.
Law enforcement at the
border is doing a great job,
but the laws they are forced
to work with are insane.
When people, with or without
children, enter our country,
they must be told to
leave without our country
being forced to endure
a long and costly trial.
Tell the people "Out" and they must leave,
just as they would if they were
standing on your front lawn.
Hiring thousands of judges does not work
and is not acceptable.
Only country in the world that does this.
So you can see what Trump is doing here
is speaking directly to the people
and asking them to influence Congress
in support of his policy stance.
So using Twitter allows Trump to speak to
more than 50 million followers,
and it allows the president
to have a rapid response
to events as they unfold.
So instead of having
to wait for a newspaper
to print an editorial
tomorrow or on Sunday,
it's possible to speak to the electorate
within minutes of an
important event happening.
So overall, modern
technology and social media
have really increased the
impact of the president's power
to communicate with the electorate,
to get out policy initiatives
and to advertise them,
and to speak quickly and
directly to the people.